the moon is a great place to this game
it establishes a whole new set of
promises for a boy dansgame the place
that gave us the most freedom to really
have to do whatever he wanted was well
some way that line between world lands
one and two between bordeaux has one
more lines - we have this really
interesting story that was never told in
Berlin's ones moon is a solid piece of
rock in four lines - it's all cracked
and damaged something kind of changed up
there when people like blow lands -
there's a Hyperion Space Station and
there's lava cracks all over the moon
the Australian guys really wanted to
explore that yeah we wanted to tour that
- and also all our fans wanted to go to
the moon
so we basically decided to play around
with what you can and can't do in a
Borderlands game to sort of push the
envelope of like what if go to the moon
enough freeze guns snipe laser guns to
have all this crazy stuff these things
that we've never tried the borderlands
game before would that still feel cooler
would it still feel like the borderlands
game and the pre-sequel was an attempt
to sort of take some risks and answer
some of those questions and then
hopefully we've succeeded
yeah because I did notice in my testing
as well that if you like blood rush up
okay with a jet pack or something and
you missed because he moved out of the
way you can get some serious hi-yah
which is very fun but maybe the art guys
will kill us even before we start
working on bottle answers we saw message
boards and everything like people want
to go to the nude
there was a very first goal in this game
but opened this massive wealth of
opportunities of us to to kind of change
up the gameplay it's the same comport
lands gameplay they really really like
with some new twists that actually
changed the game more than you would
think yeah you can jump really high and
you can use the oxygen for jetpacks
you can use laser weapons for the first
time and upload a landscape and there's
the really fun things that you could
only do on the moon we should do so sort
of weird Easter Egg if you hop in
through there and like jump around from
these piece and somehow avoid all the
lot of explosions dagdu Priestly it's
actually claptrap he's hiding back there
right the low gravity feels completely
different it adds this completely new
dimension to the gameplay and it changes
up the combat spaces it's given our
level designers is this freedom to kind
of go crazy from their imagination we do
want to just kind of have like you know
floating jumps and I feel like stuck in
the air for ages and things like that
and we did like a playground early on if
I work out how to make gravity a really
interesting fun dynamic and moving at
great levels a lot of verticality and a
lot of platforms that were high up and
after our initial kind of experiments we
kind of settled on something which extra
turned out to be really fun
we sold the the problem with being
flooding the air for ages by having this
kind of slam kind of ability my thoughts
on but stop is that but stomp is
hilariously fun the buck slam is just a
wonderful piece of gameplay it's just go
to slam technically but I have to call
it buck slam it's just too much fun to
say that there's nothing like being in
the air and being able to just drop down
on somebody and stagger them and juice
dude a couple shots and a head shots and
suddenly to go down and it's just a
blast the cria weapons have been a
really fun one for us to to implement
one of our program is really early on
who's really keen on creating some kind
of ice shattering kind of tech we
actually have this really cool system
that will freeze enemies so initially
when you start shooting them they'll
start to slow down they'll start turning
a little bit blue but then you can
actually freeze them solid and if
they're frozen solid you get their
health low enough you can actually
shatter them you can either run into
them and melee them they'll shatter into
these beautiful ice jars floating off
but also one of my favorite things to do
is free someone from above and slam down
and shatter them and we'll also work
with like laser weapons with if you have
a laser and you slice through guards
made of ice who actually pull apart into
two pieces so that kind of combined with
a low gravity and other things it's it's
really changing the way that you play
ball ends and I think players are gonna
really like it
they're really going to enjoy and the
payoff is going to be huge moment
well you become one of the vault hunters
one of the heroes that's sort of working
with handsome jack
during his rise to power everybody loved
Nisha she was this character that we all
regret killing off spoiler she's worse
than handsome Jack in many ways like she
just enjoys strangling on these cups a
little bit of a little bit in common
yeah there's a little bit of
unpredictable his action skill as his
lunacy Oh eNOS she was a badass warrior
type what if he played his hurt so it's
a really interesting timeline and it's
it's really fun and it's really
eye-opening